okay so I'm for him and I work on
financial data feeds and I develop here
and there and some other internet
related stuff but this is really one of
our focuses about financial data feeds
and what we'll be talking about is about
wolfram finance platform now Wolfen
finance platform is built on Wolfram
language and it is not a subset of
Wolfram language that you get in
Mathematica it's the whole thing plus a
little bit more so we'll be talking
about that so this is the current
functionality we'll talk about what
exists today in wolfram finance platform
what is up next you can see the targeted
audience and who will be useful who can
really benefit from it so currently we
have Bloomberg terminal it's a very fun
as a piece of software that lives on
your machine and it is quick it receives
data from Bloomberg terminal and cert
and so you can extract the data into the
finance platform you can communicate it
using the Wolfram language the other
functionality that we offer with finance
platform is the CUDA and has computation
so there are a few functions that kind
of for example financial derivative you
can set the option to the GPU and your
computation will happen there and so
I'll give you a small preview of what
that looks like
now remember so the Bloomberg terminal
most of it is cashed out there so we're
not going to actually do it but some of
the stuff we will but some stuff we
won't so here is the overview current
data feeds
to face data feeds and we'll talk about
the entity framework I'm sure if you
attend to Steve is talk yesterday a lot
of things will seem familiar to you and
I will talk about authentication which
is useful when we are talking about
financial data feeds what different
kinds of attend occasions do they use
then we'll touch a bit on task framework
and we'll see a prototype of the
scheduled interface and then we might
talk about compatibility so currently
wolfram finance platform is only
supported on Windows why because
Bloomberg terminal only works on Windows
that's what it is so if you had finance
platform this is the few things you'd
have to do you have to do market e to
connect it once you get the data source
you would be able to look at different
kinds of data and it's it's a bit ad hoc
in its current form and that's what will
go forward and make it more plain that
is more useful so you could get the
snapshot where it just gives you a value
all you could get a time series and you
had to give this know it is pretty dated
giving to 2017 one five this is not nice
anymore and then you could also get the
real-time data and the kernel interface
to it is sort of ad hoc you'd have to do
these marketing to subscribe market at a
subscription start marketing to get now
this was released in version 9 so two
versions which is many years ago and we
did not have task framework so we'll
talk about how that has become more
useful
okay so now we'll look into different
products that are more platform friendly
one of them as Bloomberg data license it
works over HTTP protocol and though it
is not real-time it is very profuse you
get lots of data and different
commodities company history company data
and so on then there is the Reuter
ultra performance api which now they
have renamed to reuters ETA
they keep on changing names sometimes
but it used to be ultra performance it's
a very low-level api it talks directly
on the socket level and it's rather
useful so thus for real-time data and
then there is the Bloomberg terminal
will revamp that a little bit too okay
so there is actually a way in the
Wolfram language currently that you ask
for data and that is through the entity
framework and here are a few examples so
you have this take entity country and
you get the properties so these are the
things that you can ask the wolf the
Alpha database I want some properties
and Norway is the country and those are
the first few properties that you can
ask for and then once you do this you
get this really nice quantity and so
this is pretty rich way of actually
doing computation as you can talk to
your students when you're talking and
you know they understand this it's not
just a number and then you have the you
can ask for a time series and it knows
that you're asking for a date so I
should give you time series
so getting from point A to point B here
is rather simple
then currently through some api's that
are through alpha we provide you some
financial data which is already built in
normal Mathematica and the Wolfram
language of that so here is the
financial Nasdaq MSFT here are the few
properties the total or just 61 and you
can ask for the last price that will
give you that NFA at one time series so
this is what it feels like to write code
using Wolfram language to get data out
of these different sources you can do
all this rather easily
and if you look at the time series you
get a quantity array and if I take an
element you get the units so I'm going
to skip the next section and come later
to it so how does this look with
external sources so here's an example we
just say entity row it is ETA and there
it is
so voice is ETA is the API or the
service that you want to connect to and
get the data and then you can do
multiple sensor you bet and ask and here
is a more verbose way of asking for time
series from Bloomberg terminal which you
saw that market data cells and we'd have
to give it complicated syntax but this
is the right thing to do here then the
entity framework also supports different
annotations because you may not want you
may want to organize your data in
certain way that it is more accessible
or so here's in a way we have done it
with entity property Association we can
do it at a set of thoughts and here's an
example of asking for time series of
bloom Microsoft and Vodafone a London
London equity and you get this properly
decent output that you expect now how do
we hook the external API is into the
current framework so if you were at
Stephens talk he talked about custom
entities and I think he if I remember
correctly he was showing some database
with our bugs and he was using entity
framework to get data from our bugs
database so I'm going to go back and
show a little bit code that goes into
custom entities where you can define
your own class so here I have some
fields that I can say fulfils and now I
have this foo service where this is
complicated code we'll get over it
and then now you have an entity store I
prepared this to the existing store and
I can ask for things like this entity
through service field what are the
properties now when I ask for properties
ask I want to get some data what do I do
so that's the fetch data and this can be
any function that you like if you have
your own database whatever query it is
whatever API you want to have you just
replace fetch data with your own code or
the sequel or we have database link so
you can add that code in here
so that's the technology that we have
built on so when we say Wolfram language
is built on Wolfram language that's what
that means really if we use custom
entities and things like that to build
this up and one of the proper advantages
of these financial data feeds is
sometimes data comes where it's very
late you ask for something and they say
it's not ready yet ask for it later and
you go there after 10 minutes and so how
are we going to do that so we in 11 - we
recently in 11 - we had task framework
is a way to hide latency it doesn't do
concurrently evaluation but be stuck so
here's an example so we had you also met
some time ago I think it even in 11:1 we
had something like that
so and it this thing will print if I can
go to the window and look at my messages
so here it has printed some data
and then I will do so this is sort of
asynchronous well it is asynchronous
actually it is happening in a thread out
there but I'll do dynamic of that it
doesn't hold up the kernel now these
were a bit quick example so you didn't
really see something otherwise kind of
wouldn't hold up now here's another
example about sessions submit it will
pause for 5 seconds but it will do it in
a task so if I do this you'll see it's
started running and then if I were to go
the messages and it would say removed at
5 seconds after
so how do we put this into finance fees
and when is that but before we go back
go to that we I really want to talk
about authentication now when you're
talking to these api's sometimes yeah
yourself with them and there are
multiple ways one of them is o earth
which is over HTTP and the other one is
client certificate and on all platforms
renounce about client certificate I
think in 11 - we made sure that all the
platforms Linux Windows and OS X which
support these and which allows us to
really hurt Bloomberg data license which
is based on HTTP protocol to be
available on all platforms and this is
how it looks like you just install your
certificate and it's just an example
with the Firefox but really on OSX you
will do it on keychain on vendors you
will use your internet options to
install that and then Wolfram language
will just know about it and it will work
that thus the girl we just try to make
things simpler and that is the idea now
schedule subnet is based on the task
framework and here's an example so
here's a schedule service that you
submit and this will stream the latest
the code time and millisecond is just
time in milliseconds when the trade half
once you started the Oh is the
connection it represents the connection
to the ETA now that is a bit more
complicated oh it's not the purpose of
this talk but I can show you later how
that works and this syntax that you see
over here is very similar to the
documented functionality certain subnet
and whatnot and if you look closely this
if you are a user of our service
functionality Service Connect Twitter
Facebook I think they have quite a few
of those out there it looks something
similar to it so the syntax is very
concise and continuous means running
forever this is streaming data
asynchronously and it's going to keep it
pushing it and it's going to print it in
the message window now Reuters it's not
supported on OS X so I'm not going to do
a preview of that but so that's the idea
you just start it and you forget about
it and you make decisions without
holding up the kernel now going back to
Bloomberg data license API the way it
works is that you send a request to
blame the data license service and they
say ok we have received your request but
we haven't made the data available come
after a minute or so we are not going to
define that time Bloomberg says and so
we just keep on asking over and over
again is it ready is it ready is it
ready and at some point they say yes and
here it is and often that time as you
will see over here it takes hundred and
fifty seconds which is pretty slow and
so we want to avoid that that's why we
start using this task framework which is
become really useful for us and it has
started the task I can do one one I can
add one plus one without holding the
kernel
it's just contrived really okay and that
you can do and then this is another
example of take data and this gives you
a data that is really really large
that's you should be in the kernel if I
haven't restarted it yeah so if I look
at the take data just to show you how
the fuse Bloomberg is it has 36,000 NS
not even in the notebook thus the amount
of data that they can send it your way
which can be really useful to train your
machine learning stuff if you are doing
finance and things like god it might be
a good training set okay so that's
pretty much the overview and I'd go to
these particular talks I think Tom when
he was talking in the next room he
mentioned a few of those and Anthony is
working on Wolfram cloud connector for
Excel which is useful and these fields
of Finance but that's what I have